du weisst was das ist
das sinnlose her kennt das ist das
fragen wir sind auch wieder fragen hier
geht es ja nur um fragen fragen über
fragen die roten sind unverschämte
fragen die grünen haben so sitzt man
hofft ja es stimmt
du kannst mehr da wo ich du kannst
wählen was du willst es ist bisher noch
keiner wutentbrannt rausgerannt aber das
ist sowieso kiesbett wieder bedeutung
rot und grün ja rote sind die
unverschämten fragen ach so sie in 30
gemeinden hintersinn immer kleine
unterstellungen drin ok ich rot
werde ich jetzt schon über misst dann
vielleicht ein bisschen böse dies vorher
genau du willst wissen was noch wenn ich
rede über denkt
ich finde dich sexy es von dir
hast du wegen deiner unzuverlässigkeit
schon freunde verloren
also ist klar dass freunde mal sauer
waren auf mich weil ich mich jetzt nicht
gemeldet habe weil ich halt irgendwie in
berlin bin und ich komme mir verboten
sehen und waren doch ein bisschen
beleidigt umso aber sobald ich merke
dass wirklich alle krass abgefragt kann
dann rufe ich alibimäßig an und so
liegen die china vor allem wie mäßig
spätestens jetzt wer jetzt bewerben
freude
ja so noch nie hatte die richtigen
freunde die alten immer zu sein und da
irgendwas anspruch und ist ein sehr
guter spruch da ist das ganze leben ist
in der zugfahrt viele leute steigen ein
und viele steigen auch wieder aus aber
nur ganz wenige begleiten dich zu deinem
ziel
und da sind dann aber ich jetzt ein paar
herzen mädchen herzen gebrochen wir
dieses buch
ich hab' ich habe den extra dicken
auswendig gelernt
hast du das wort der sind widerspruch
der stimmt gutes buch der stimmt und bei
erst wird der junge gibt es ein paar
zugbegleiter es gibt noch mal gut aber
gerne
also bushido sido hat das war heute auch
wenn die musiker vorbei ist dann immer
freunde bleiben
brüder
so
wieso hast du es nicht mal mit einem
richtigen beruf probiert so sind es
jetzt nicht ändern oder anleihen sowie
der haltung seine der installateur nicht
ich wollte immer rapper sein und ich bin
auch sehr froh dass ich es gemacht habe
hätte ich mich damals an der schule
angestrengt so dann wäre ich heute
vielleicht bankkaufmann oder irgendwas
so aber dann werde ich rapper weist so
das heißt du kannst noch zwei hochzeiten
gleichzeitig gleichzeitig kannst
entweder machst du das oder du machst
das aber hätte ich jetzt ein bisschen
gerappt und bisschen schule angestrengt
da wäre ich heute nicht hier also habe
ich gesagt okay du musst dich
entscheiden also
werde ich die schule an den nagel hängen
und nochmal ne rote ja gerne gerne gerne
da ist aber musiker und penner ist ja
dicht beieinander wollen wir also muss
ich sagen er ist musiker keinen erfolg
hast dann bist du penner
weil dann hast du keine chance geld zu
verdienen dann wenn man gute freunde hat
wird man niemals penner die müssen aber
dann auch gut bei kasse sei oder du hast
dir einfach eine reiche frau wenn du
noch erfolgreich bin da hast du wieder
vorteile die andere auch nicht unbedingt
sagen hast du die fragen geschrieben
auch auch aber wir sammeln da wären sie
kann auch an der moral du hast schon
viele [__] kennengelernt willst du
nicht mal eine richtige freundin doch
will ich ich hab ich will das wort nicht
benutzen das sagt man nicht mehr sagt
man nicht immer nur weil du ja klar ist
ich habe diese diese ganzen frauen so
sagt und ich bin auch wirklich auch
versuche noch etwas fest um endlich das
weil ich hab ja auch eine feste
beziehung vor einem jahr dann werde ich
mal dass die letzte unverschämte frage
öffnen und dann kommt die alu
erholungsphase wenn du nicht mal zwei
grüne danach ja gerne auch die das sind
aber so fahren die höchstwahrscheinlich
täglich so aus dem topf warum bist du so
toll
lachen nicht viele wenn du einen auf
dicke hose macht es war er kann auf die
kurse
also in realität nicht nur in seinen
liedern und songs in deinen raps in
deines alles leid erinnern lernen
ist auf dem roten teppich nicht auch so
hey guck mal hier uhr brille
uhr brille jacke noch mal wie sich die
kammer zur brille jacke noch einmal
ganz
nah wie gesagt natürlich es gibt immer
immer neider und irgendwelche hater so
die sie nicht kennen aber die sonne
ruhig lachen weil im endeffekt so
so das ist einfach mein mann mein
lebensziel den leb ich auch und
so ein kleiner angeber steckt auch in
jedem von uns ist natürlich unsinn wir
waren der vorkriegs tun
okay kommt jetzt noch mal eine grüne
hier kommen zwei wochen noch offen
so werde ich doch ganz schnell
beantworten die für euch weil jetzt
schon aufzuhören mit meiner moderation
mal vergleich kommt vielleicht tut mir
leid ich muss noch eine grüne frage
lesen so was macht dich so attraktiv
recht ist
das war das perfekte sind die
philippinischen augen seiner mutter die
augen meiner mutter machen nicht so
attraktiv so die grünen so viel besser
ausstatten lassen roten aufgemacht woher
hast du deine muckis sie bloß
das geheimnis vorteilhaft vorteilhaft
anziehen jaja das heißt ich könnte auch
so aussehen wie du ich glaube jetzt
einfach sein damit so mit
schulterpolstern auf den 80er jahren das
ist ja gleich aus ivan drago also das
heißt dass das hier ist auch
eingearbeitet ins hemd
über mad men so von bene hast du deine
musikalität
dort natürlich muss nicht nur
musikalisch ist da freue ich mich
manchmal selber wie
ist das wenn du wenn du ja irgendwann in
den kopf kommt ist also ein göttlicher
moment hab ich mal darüber gesprochen
helmut zerlett habe ich mal drüber
gesprochen ist der verrat genau und der
hat erzählt er ich kann sich eigentlich
irgendwie so ein göttlicher moment wenn
mir was einfällt dann ist das eine
eingebung ich kann gar nicht sagen dass
ich das selbst erfunden habe es kommt
was macht nicht so erfolgreich
ich glaube einfach meine meine meine
einzigartigkeit
in dieser musik denn es gibt einfach es
gibt wo ein qimonda es gibt auch keinen
so der es schafft wie ich zurück ich
noch zu machen ich bin da wirklich ein
unikat
jetzt hat er ja was mache ich jetzt auf
dem rhein gucken
bäte nicht
solche videos machen wir nicht
beweisen dass man damit auch mal gern
ein
super super hammer